just like Batman himself the Joker
didn't arrive fully formed he is how we
got from a one-shot gimmick villain to
the embodiment of madness and mayhem and
how he was almost completely forgotten
along the way it might be hard to
believe these days but when he first sat
the pages of 1939 Batman wasn't exactly
an original concept Bill Finger and Bob
Kane were heavily influenced by the
shadow a pop vigilante who eventually
found himself replaced in the pop
culture pantheon by Batman in fact the
story that introduced Batman the case of
the chemical syndicate was to put it
charitably inspired by a shadow novel
called partners of peril that have been
released a few years earlier if you
don't want to be charitable you might
even say it was lifted wholesale before
long of course Batman emerged as his own
character six months after his debut he
got the origins story that remains
unchanged to this day and five months
after that finger and Jerry Robinson
introduced Robin who redefined the idea
of a sidekick and inspired a thousand
knockoffs himself still those stories
were never exactly subtle about where
they were digging up their ideas enter
German actor conrad veidt in 1928 he
starred in a silent film called the man
who laughs about a 17th century nobleman
named grim plain his father had been
killed in an Iron Maiden by political
rivals and as for Quinn plane himself it
has figured him by cutting his mouth
into a smile quote so that he may laugh
forever at his fall of a father when
playing grows up gets revenge and
actually gets a much happier ending than
he gets in the Victor Hugo novel on
which the film was based the important
part for the new Batman comics however
was his striking image of a man whose
face was permanently twisted into a grin
forced a smile no matter what emotion he
was actually feeling something that
fight did very well in the film finger
was inspired by that incredible visual
and poor the idea to Jerry Robinson
thinking up a new villain for that comic
and the tape of this guy no Jack mean
kid
bad seed hurt people I like him already
Batman issue one hit the shelves of 1940
and kicked off with one of the golden
ages most memorable images the Joker
smiling at the reader while plotting a
string of murders
right from the first panel that Joker
wasn't settling for the same reason that
vice performance was memorable in the
film a total disconnect between emotion
and expression from page one in a very
literal sense there's something off
about him and the story of course bears
else the Joker racks up a dozen kills in
his first appearance and when he comes
back for a second story later in that
same issue there's a visceral quality to
his particular brand of violence at odds
with a stiff art that's so common in the
Golden Age clearly the craters were onto
something even if they didn't realize it
the Joker was originally intended to die
at the end of the first story like most
of Batman's early foes dead but said
it's a Whitney Ellsworth decided to keep
him around and the last panel of the
Joker's body being hauled away was
changed to have the doctor's surprise
that it survived instead it wasn't long
until the Joker as a character ran up
against a problem with the arrival of
Robin the Batman titles has started to
skew towards a younger audience
following the example of extremely
profitable heroes like Superman
the Joker was already popular enough to
stick around but he changed to keep up
with the times leaning hard into the
goofy clown aesthetic of his personality
rather than the serial killer surf there
have been a huge part of his debut a
crucial element that the Joker kept
through the sillier years was that he
was never given a real name or a
definitive origin story which is pretty
remarkable comics back then were
dedicated to explaining every single
piece of their mythology to the point
would that eventually have Batman
encounter the guy who killed his parents
and then later encounter the guy who
really killed his parents by hiring the
first guy that story also explains where
Batman really got the idea for his
costume his dad had a bat costume that
he was to a costume party which had
already been explained back in 1939 the
closest anyone came to explaining the
Joker was in the man behind the Red Hood
in 1951 the thing is that story doesn't
actually tell us anything new I don't
know what caddy cigars
we never learned the red hoods real name
we never see his face or we find out is
that he's had multiple identities and
that there were things in his past that
even Batman the world's greatest
detective doesn't know even better we
find out that he was willing to leap
into a vat of toxic chemicals rather
than be apprehended by the police even
before he's the Joker he's got a
disregard for human life even his own as
an origin story the man behind the red
hood only served to make the Joker more
mysterious if he wasn't always a joker
was he even really the Joker now were
there more identities in the past those
questions would remain a part of the
character for the next 70 years believe
it or not there was a time when the
Joker wasn't around in the pages of
Batman or Detective Comics
but it wasn't because of a lack of
popularity at least not on a large scale
there was one audience for whom the
Joker was decidedly unpopular
and while it was an audience of exactly
one person it turns out to be the one
that mattered the most Julius Schwartz
who took over editing Batman and
detective in 1964 was said by co-workers
to have absolutely hated the character
as a results the Joker's role in the
core Batman titles dropped off
dramatically and after the Batman TV
show ended in 1969 Schwartz apparently
didn't see any reason to keep him around
at all for the next four years to 1969
to September 1973 to be precise there
weren't any new Joker stories in those
two comics and just two in books
Schwartz wasn't editing in 1973 though
Schwartz apparently had a change of
heart
or was convinced that four years was
long enough to go without a villain that
readers still liked the result is one of
the most memorable Batman comics ever
the Joker's five-way revenge by Denny
O'Neil and Neal Adams will they kill
load of me
the team would wind up contributing some
pretty huge elements the Batman mythos
they co-created Ra's al Ghul among
others and there Neal would himself
spent about 15 years as the editor of
the Batman comics bringing over right
sir artists Frank Miller for Marvel for
an ambitious project about Batman's
later years when he left Marvel even
with all that though this might be the
most important work it wasn't just a
reintroduction of the Joker both in
universe and for the readers it was
arguably the single story that created
the modern Joker as the title suggests
he's out for revenge
not against Batman but against his own
henchmen the story established that
Joker had been imprisoned in and escaped
from a hospital for the criminally
insane rather than a prison which would
eventually lead O'Neill and earth Novick
to create Arkham Asylum eight months
later it also brought back the poison
that a left has victim to smiling
corpses back in his first appearances
and crucially establish that his plans
weren't necessarily driven by logic only
one of the five henchmen targeted in the
story had actually betrayed him to the
police but Joker didn't know which one a
solution killed them all by poison
bombing and even feeding one to a shark
this was the story that truly ramped up
the Joker's insanity and was a
foundation on which everything else was
built
if the Joker wasn't Batman's true
arch-nemesis before then he certainly
was after it's worth noting that the
revitalization of the Joker and his
increasingly unpredictable madness
wasn't just a product of O'Neil and
Adams a few years later in 1978 Steve
englehardt and marshal Rogers another
creative team hired away from Marvel
knocked another definitive Joker story
out of the park the Laughing fish for
his part Rogers work here is considered
some of the all-time best Batman art
with good reason and like a few other
artists he plays as small as a permanent
fixture on the Joker's face rather than
just an expression
harkening back to Veidt and the man who
laughs as Hertz it was an updated
retelling of the first story from Batman
issue 1 a Joker sets off on a string of
murders announcing his targets while in
advance to terrorize the city before
leaving them with their poison smiles
but there was one big twist
rather than being random death in
destruction The Joker's reason for the
murders or at least the excuse he was
using was that his victims were keeping
him from getting a patent on fish
poisoned with his signature smile it is
a bizarre motive and that's exactly why
it works the other villains might have
fixations and obsessions but the Joker
was completely beyond reason
demanding something so ridiculous from
bureaucrats was a challenge to the very
concept of an ordered world he quite
simply could not be reasoned with
because in his view reason didn't even
exist
throughout the 70s and 80s the Batman
comment on sort of a pendulum swinging
to one extreme gritty violent
street-level crime dramas to the other
the pop art camp of the 60s he was still
a superhero but stories light there is
no hope in the Crime Alley and to kill a
legend I'd pulled the focus onto the
idea of how people deal with tragedies
that same lens with applied to the
villains to Batman's galeria foes went
from a solid roster of baddies with
great gimmicks and interesting hooks to
a group of villains who have reworked
into being specific psychological foils
for the hero to face for instance became
explicitly cast as a tragic figure who
was struggling with his own two extremes
of good and evil and what it was like to
look into the mirror and see something
that was more like a mask looking back
at you the Riddler had always had a
superiority complex but now it was about
proving the Batman and everything he
stood for could fail Bane explored the
idea of someone with Bruce Wayne's keen
minds and gifted athleticism being born
into crime corruption and poverty
instead of a life of privilege the Joker
was ahead of the curve but the same
change is happening with him he stopped
being merely unpredictable becoming an
embodiment of madness and nihilism he
represented a moral threat that went far
beyond just punching him out and
dragging him back to Arkham Asylum and
the thing is he's kind of had to evolve
that way because Batman was undergoing
the same change himself as a man of
flesh and blood I can be ignored I can
be destroyed but it's a symbol
as a symbol I can be incorruptible say
what you will about the shark repellent
bat spray seen in the 66 movie but if
you get right down to it it actually is
a pretty accurate portrayal of how
Batman works as a character he's
entirely built around the idea of
determination there's some beatable well
to win he evolved from just having the
tagline of the world's greatest
detective into embodying the phrase
becoming the character who thought of
everything
and was always one step ahead because he
had to be because if he wasn't people
died and that became the consequence
death it had always been there going all
the way back to the origin story but in
the 80s it was codified into the core of
the character and that's Batman's
definitive arch nemesis the Joker
evolved to embody it he is the
consequence that's why the Joker was the
one who killed Robin which stood for
years as Batman's greatest failure
that's why he was a central character in
The Killing Joke where Alan Moore and
Brian Bolland go back to that Red Hood
story from 1951 and rework it into its
own kind of tragedy and it's why every
time he showed up after those
consequences are to keep getting more
dire more destructive more of an assault
on the very concepts of Batman was built
on that's how the Joker became the
twisted a moral character that we have
today the only real question is how much
more twisted he can get check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos but your favorite
comic book characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one